ah my moment of triumph it's gone the
picture is gone
[Music]
I can't get away from spider-man no
matter how hard I try I think I'm just
permanently associated with the
character because I got my start more or
less by reviewing all of his videogames
then I made the foolish mistake of
sewing his costume together myself and
taught an entire generation of teenage
boys how to make clothes a useful skill
for the coming near apocalypse of oh
nine and then I explained why I thought
miles was better written in spider-verse
than in the comics and that got 1.4
million views it's gotten so bad that
when I open Commission's to make cosplay
props for people
despite explicitly saying I won't do web
shooters I got nothing but requests for
those I was in talks with another
youtuber to do a collaboration and he
said well I don't really do spider-man
videos on my channel so I don't know
what we can work on together despite
that dozens and dozens of videos I've
made about other things so I kind of
swore it off for a while just to save
myself some stress until I checked
patreon one day and someone donated the
$100 tear for a video request but not
only did he give $100 he gave 500
Jonathan Stubbs is insane madman with
too much expendable income and a burning
passionate desire to hear me talk about
these cartoons very few people have ever
been that generous to little old me
before and I feel like I owe it to the
guy to at least try despite my newfound
arachnophobia maybe it'll be fun to
reminisce and talk about the old
webslinger again perhaps looking at
these shows with a new perspective and
future context will reveal something
interesting about them that hasn't been
talked about yet and maybe I'll finally
collapse on my desk editing videos
because I finally built up a tolerance
to caffeine and my neural electroshock
crown shorted out if there's something
you desperately want to hear me talk
about you can donate to the $100 tier on
my patreon to request a review just for
you but even a one dollar donation helps
me immensely if just three percent of my
subscribers donated only $1 a month I
wouldn't need a side job to make ends
meet and I could devote a lot more time
to make
and paying editors they'll help me get
other ones out too please consider
helping a brother out now on to
tonight's main presentation being the
overnight sensation that saved the
amazing fantasy comic line and launched
a new era for the Marvel Comics Empire
spider-man quickly became a hot property
in the early 1960s and hasn't lost that
momentum since with such a colorful and
dynamic design such broad and appealing
stories in such a unique
characterization people couldn't get
enough of the webhead it only seemed
logical to broaden his appeal outside of
the comics with some of Marvel's
first-ever licensed merchandise and
eventually so with that let's take it
back to the swinging 60s and talk about
that goofy [ __ ] everyone's made a
million memes over and doesn't take
seriously a show that's often looked
past because of its reputation of just
being cheesy garbage with animation
errors galore surges logical paradoxes
and an ever-changing visual style that's
so much fun to plaster with the impact
fond however it's actually kind of good
well okay hear me out good as a relative
term in this case as stated this shows
got a lot of problems more problems than
you can shake a web at I thought [ __ ]
but there's a few episodes throughout it
that are really solid for the time I've
often heard people miss credit the 90s
animated show is the first superhero
cartoon to adapt stories from the comics
but the show is riddled with really
accurate recreations of classic Stan Lee
and Steve Ditko stories sometimes right
down to the dialogue being used word for
word granted it's not always as pretty
to look at as Steve's legendary
penciling but occasionally the show
tries to get really accurate and just
flat-out traces his art in animation
cells to bring it to life I can't tell
if that's cool or a little legally
dubious but the part that attracts me to
this shows better episodes is that I
feel like the people behind it for
better or for worse
understood spider-man as a character
he's a badass superhero that feels it's
his personal responsibility to save the
day
even though that heroism cost him in his
personal and social life spider-man is a
genius confident wisecracking hero with
the strength to rival most Avengers but
when he takes off the mask he's a guy
who can't catch a break and always feels
like he's getting
shortened to the stick so now the series
against all odds' captures that essence
in its own universe pretty well let's
take the first episode for example it's
a little weird that Peter is driving a
car but he gets into a bit of an
accident on the outskirts of the city
while on assignment for the bugle in
trying to salvage his ride he
accidentally uncovers doc Ock's secret
lair where he's setting up a plan to
create a man-made underground shock wave
that will demolish New York with
earthquakes and his dialogue is pretty
on point
[Music]
[Music]
like these are good quips man that's how
spider-man talks Jay jonah jameson is
pulled straight from the comics Doc Ock
feels like he was written by Stan Lee
himself
spider-man's voice actor the great Paul
souls even makes his voice sound softer
and weaker as Peter Parker but manly and
confident as spider-man this is all
about I'm gonna get some pictures for
old Jake jonah jameson whatever it is
you may be put off by the light-hearted
and comical tone but spider-man is an
incredibly versatile character when it
comes to tone they're just as many silly
stories for the character as there are
dark and gritty ones and yet both seem
to work for him when handled properly by
the right people as it turns out we did
Co and even John Romita senior all had a
bit of a hand in the character design in
this first season and story consulting I
was really blown away by this first
episode because I wasn't expecting this
to be as competent as it is but then
reality sets in and then you remember
this has 22 minute episodes and that the
first daring adventure only lasted a
prompt 10 minutes and 51 seconds then
the second half plays a spider-man takes
on the famed villain ice aliens from
Pluto okay this is where I think the
criticisms are mostly founded this show
has two types of episodes really cool
adventures with comic villains and some
pretty snappy writing and really bizarre
stuff where they tried to create their
own villains for him to fight to save on
the budget often filled with really
nonsensical stories and clunky animation
[Music]
[Applause]
but even then they get the basics right
Spidey still a science whiz he's still
clever and smack talks the bad guys and
he still gets shafted as Peter Parker by
his exploits so I can't hate on it too
much I understand the necessity to
create a new antagonist when you've got
a weekly show and need to produce 52
episodes to play in syndication but at
this point in history Spidey was still
only around for less than 5 years and
didn't have this infinite well of
characters and stories to pull from but
the demand for more of this runaway
success of a character was huge they
only had a handful of source material to
use and it looks like they tried their
best to pull as much from it as possible
I really like this effect from
Mysterio's helmet and I kind of want to
see that done with like a newer setting
and smoother animation unfortunately
though this show had a shoestring budget
and couldn't afford to keep buying
character rights as it went on in season
two and three are pretty devoid of new
comic villains it's probably what holds
this show back from being beloved in an
unacceptable
I can't get my hands on any concrete
numbers but it's kind of well-known that
like you know did you just look at it
now let's not discount animation at the
time and say this was like the best you
could do with the right money behind a
project you could get like Disney
quality or the godlike Fleischer
Superman cartoons with smooth fluid
movement and detailed character shading
that [ __ ] came out in 1941 and I think
it looks better than most stuff being
made now 60 spider-man is unfortunately
bogged down by the fact that the
production company grant ray Laurence
animation wanted to throw money at it
meaning the end result looks like
classic demon or that god-awful Star
Trek cartoon and you don't want to hear
all these excuses and this positivity
you want to hear me complain and mock
this thing because outrage sells alright
it's bitching time Spiderman building
complex structures out of webbing is
stupid makes zero sense and there's our
shocking amount of convenient
construction equipment laying around for
him to drive how the [ __ ] do you color
is costume with this wrong there's so
few drawings made for this show overall
that they reuse animations constantly
which means animation errors are almost
constant too like his logo having the
incorrect amount of legs webs don't
attach to anything like an unfortunate
amount of video games in fact there are
whole episodes that are reused
animations characters are often stiff as
hell
spider-man is off model in pretty much
every shot what does that mean you may
ask
typically animated shows will have a
character model sheet to draw their
different poses from the consistency's
sake lack of consistency in Peter Parker
and Spidey makes me wonder if they even
had a model sheet because his eyes logos
webs and face changes frequently as the
perspective cuts to a new angle and
don't even get me started on the sound
mixing
[Music]
almost wondering what this show would
feel like with more modern sound mixing
let's test that
[Music]
well that was [ __ ] weird yeah the
show definitely has its flaws and I'd
say a lot of its reputation is founded
but I feel like people don't often give
it enough props for the episodes that it
got right because they're classic
unfettered Spider Man I'll just have to
prove Spider Man's innocence another way
[Applause]
happen to us later
[Music]
like better to witness spider-man uncle
van is dead him in the sense it's really
I guilty because I didn't realize any
time but with great power there must
also always be great responsibility
but I know it now
spider-man will never shirk his duty
[Music]
robbers killers beware
spider-man is here
this show probably had the most accurate
recreation of amazing fantasy 15 ever
adapted to screen so sure while it has
its quirks and fair share of weirdness
it's not entirely terrible and if you
ignore some of those weirder parts I
think it's actually worth watch for fans
of the character oh god I have it I want
to take this retrospective a little
slower and instead of cramming 4 reviews
into a single video really give each
show room to breathe
Plus it takes a long time to watch an
entire TV show front to back so be
patient tune in next time for the
continuation we're Spidey can finally
afford extra puff paint and he has a few
above-average bros to tag along and help
[Music]
[Music]